but a game of football can obviously
last 95 minutes depending on the extra
time period that the referee will put on
how do you prevent that too often
performers that quite often happens in
the second half of the match I repeat
players who from a BlueCross minutes
half times our big opportunity to take
some cards on board and top up in that
period after 45 minutes of that first
breaking play is your opportunity to get
something on board from a halftime
perspective you know we keep things
quite simple we use the science in sport
energy gels to support with the
carbohydrate requirements for legs
running the game
that's seem to indicate that the second
half is the time period where most balls
are thought this glycogen depletion
taken place in players that lead to
actual mental fatigue and players making
poor decisions which then could cost
them the game
I think the jaws before going out for
the second half to give me that extra
boost the energy gels are just a real
high GI plus really source of
carbohydrates for after
[Music]